démarrer les plus beaux lieux aux
intérieurs les plus bourgeois en passant
par la cour de l'elysée il est partout
sa beauté sa douceur sa personnalité le
rendent irrésistible
mais attention sa vraie nature c'est la
chasse le labrador est un retriever
capable de plonger à trois mètres de
fond pour amener à son maître un canard
blessés ou tout simplement une pierre
quand vient l'heure du jeu la légende
veut qu'il soit né des amours d'un chien
et d'une loutre
plus sérieusement il apparaît que depuis
son débarquement d'angleterre par les
terre-neuvas les anglais se sont
attachés à l'élevage du labrador avec
beaucoup de passion et qu'aujourd'hui
encore ils ont leurs secrets
le labrador pu vivre en ville le coincer
qu'aux anglais le plus bas des lapins de
ne sont pas vendus pour la chasse y sont
tendus comme chien de compagnie il est
beaucoup en ville et qui vit très bien
mais il faut se mettre à la place de sa
chienne trouble de jaune dit qu'est ce
que la voix d'or va m'offrir trop peu
demande ce que nous visons à offrir au
labrador
quelqu'un qui cherche un labrador aura
plus de chance à trouver chez un élève
qui relève uniquement cette race et
consacre toute son énergie et sa passion
à cette race a cherché à améliorer à
suivre une certaine idéal des
particuliers certainement élèves dans
des bonnes conditions psychologiques
mais ce n'est pas nécessairement le
bonheur de la race pour une famille qui
reprend en charge une petite aide qui
est très malléable qui est très
dépendant donc apte à se faire adopter
et adopté c'est tout la famille
d'épouser toutes les façons d'être de
serment je pense que notre semaine c'est
une bonne âge voilà les papiers que je
vous donne aujourd'hui avec le chien il
y as au premier les cartes pâturages
vous allez mettre votre nom au double
vous avez aussi le carnet de vaccination
signé pour le vétérinaire
je vais vous montrer le dernier pièce
qui est le site et icade naissance ici
vous avez les 6-4 en vente quitte une
pièce obligatoire qui vous donne le nom
du chiot cela des licences son numéro de
tatouage
l'origine du labrador est encore
incertaine la théorie la plus répandue
avance l'hypothèse qu'il proviendrait de
chiens qui seconde les pêcheurs eskimos
sur les côtes du labrador au nom du
canada lors qu'on aventure s'est
poursuivi sur les voisines de
terre-neuve où au xviiie siècle écolo
anglais venus exploiter les bandes morue
admirer déjà le travail de chien encore
appelée terre-neuve de saint john qui
récupère lé poids sont échappés des
filets c'est cher présenter les
caractéristiques très similaires à ceux
des labradors actuelle il eut bientôt
temps de chien sur l'île qu'un décret
fut passé pour en limiter le nombre les
terre-neuviens décidèrent alors de céder
leurs compagnons aux marins anglais
débarqués sur les côtes de l'angleterre
il trouvait rapidement acquéreur auprès
des sportsmen leur anglais qui
appréciaient son habileté à apporter les
proies blessés aussi bien dans l'eau que
sur terre des aristocrates du comté de
dorset donnèrent le coup d'envoi
l'élevage du labrador
les premiers furent introduits dans
l'hexagone en 1896 le labrador sur
reconnu en 1903 par le kennel club en
angleterre en 1911 en france par le
retriever club de france
depuis le début de notre siècle les
chiens ont accompagné des non voyants
pour guider leurs pas les premiers
guides furent des chiens de réforme de
l'armée
par la suite des écoles spécialisées ont
pris naissance pour que l'éducation soit
psychologiquement et matériellement bien
menée à la suite d'un travail réalisé en
grande bretagne dans les années 60 une
sélection a été mise en route le
labrador s'est révélée particulièrement
adapté à ce rôle
il est sérieux responsable attentif et
développe par son apparence une
sympathie immédiate une formation
complète pour que le chien atteigne son
top niveau et d'un coût élevé
c'est donc grâce à la complaisance des
sociétés qui les parrainent que les
écoles fournissent gratuitement de
nouveaux compagnons
en france ils sont actuellement environ
800 chiens guides à partager échanger la
vie de personnes aveugles
effectivement quand j'ai eu mon chien
j'ai retrouvé
c'est le plaisir
sans contrainte
pour moi c'est chez idéal comme chez un
guide parce que
allez partout
rencontre
il adore les vents
je fais beaucoup plus confiance à mon
chien que quelqu'un dont on est 2 c
le chien nous on donne les ordres le
chien exécute mais il a une
une dessiner un pouvoir de décision
parce que par quoi on va lui demander
d'aller tout droit et il ya un camion
voiture n'importe quoi qu il
le passage le chien peut pas passer donc
c'est lui qui décide
klaus on faire confiance c'est pas un
dressage c'est une éducation quand le
sien retire on lui retire le harnais 6 1
on peut dire comme un enfant 7 h f
le chien droit ces moments de détente on
va le faire courir loi peu qu'on les
trouve quand même
détente et de loisirs parce que pour le
chien le guidage ça demande quand même
une concentration
tentons
et
en 1989 et créer l'année cap association
nationale d'éducation de chiens
d'assistance aux handicapés elle a pour
but de former des chiens qui aide les
personnes handicapées moteur dans leur
vie quotidienne
l'association sans but lucratif assure
la formation des éducateurs l'élevage et
l'éducation des chiens ainsi que
l'adaptation du chien et de l'handicapé
les chiens dits d'assistance sont
l'équivalent de ce que sont les chiens
guides aveugles pour les non-voyants
d'indispensables compagnon leur
formation rigoureuse les rend apte à
exécuter plus de 50 commandement
ramasser les objets au sol
aller chercher un téléphone ouvrir ou
fermer une porte ou tirer un fauteuil
roulant dans un passage difficile
l'aneca s'appuie sur des méthodes
éprouvées aux états unis où les chiens
d'assistance existe depuis plus de 15
ans le labrador a été choisi pour sa
souplesse de caractère sont obéissants
son dévouement la sérénité et
l'adaptabilité dont il fait preuve
malheureusement le nombre de ces chiens
d'assistance est encore très limitée
il doit n'existe qu'une douzaine en
france mais l'année cas poursuit et
intensifie son action
on peut tout on peut toujours demander
on veut en faire des chiens guides
d'aveuglé les chiens sont handicapés des
chiens de catastrophe des chiens
d'avalanche et c'est bien mais il faudra
toujours un moment quelconque retremper
ces chiens là avec nos chiens chats
échangés sont très exigeants vous savez
on en a fait quand même des petites
merveilles d'intelligence on croit que
est la voix d'or s'adresse tout seul
parce que ça rapporte
bien sûr ça rapporte naturellement la
difficulté c'est que doivent apprendre à
porter c'est de les empêcher d'aller
chercher n'importe quoi n'importe quand
n'importe comment
ils ont besoin de travailler a commenté
réjean complicité avec leurs
propriétaires
vous voyez le cas mais la pondération
cette ardeur dans la recherche
cette intelligence dans la façon
d'utiliser ses qualités olfactives la
façon d'appuis ce de s'appuyer sur
devant le son sens du marketing c'est
encore je pense que c'est actuellement
encore les meilleurs retriever à que
faut-il pour gagner at-il trial
il faut un chat via mise d'abord bien
sûr personnellement je suis très attaché
au final anglaise parce que je pense que
une des grandes qualités d'un vote river
c'est de savoir se maîtriser
alors évidemment ça il apprend rester
calmes mais pendant la battue on sait
temps d'avoir des chiens qui manifeste
de l'impatience faire des petits
gémissements s'il était alors guère en
liberté il gémit répand alors que au
bout d'une ficelle va il est toujours il
a toujours tendance à protester contre
7,7 chose qu'on vit un tournant
il n'est pas fait pour ça enchère
réussie quand il rapporte parfaitement
alors qu'il est capable de voir tomber
des pièces de gibier sans broncher et
d'aller chercher n'importe où quand on
lui demande voilà c'est ça le très sage
c'est pas aussi évident
le labrador est un chien rustique de
santé robuste
cela n'exclut pas de prendre bien sûr
certaines précautions à différents
stades de sa vie il faudra préalablement
ces derniers fugier la mer durant sa
période de gestation et à la naissance
le show doit aussi être vermifugé
jusqu'à l'âge de 6 mois à raison d'une
fois par mois
ensuite tous les deux mois jusqu'à un an
et adultes ont continué cette dernière
fugue à sion les principales maladies
contre lesquelles on vaccine sont la
maladie de carré
l'hépatite de rhubarbe bien sûr la
gastro-entérite ou parvovirose des
maladies comme la leptospirose qui sont
donc plus spécifiques pour des chiens
vivent dans les étangs et la maladie qui
s'appelle la rage voilà les cinq
principaux vaccins qui seront faire
l'animal quand les shows bien sûr
commencent à prendre leur indépendance
ils vont se promener ils ont toujours
une allure un peu pataud faut faire
attention durant la croissance des
chiots de ne pas avoir des shows qui
pousse trop vite qu'ils poussent trop
lourd
la croissance des labradors s'achève à
peu près vers l'âge de 12 à 14 mois
les maladies spécifiques qui avec
affecte le labrador au niveau des yeux
on a que l'on appelle la trophy de la
rétine et une autre pathologie au niveau
des yeux c'est une cataracte héréditaire
pour la trophy rétiniennes
malheureusement il n'a rien à faire là
cataractes ont fait toujours ici
et de l'opérer sachant que les chances
de réussite sont une réduite
on a découvert récemment une maladie qui
s'appelle l'amyotrophie héréditaire du
labrador
c'est un petit peu ce que l'on pourrait
rapprocher au mieux bâtimen les soins
que l'on peut apporter pour lutter
contre ces maladies sont surtout des
sélections génétiques d'une baie
sélection sur les reproducteurs disent
qu'elles sont pour la plupart
héréditaire l'espérance de vie du
labrador on pourrait à peu près la
situer entre 12 et 14 ans il faut savoir
qu'elle et labrador qui peuvent vivre
très vieux tout cas matin de 16 ans sans
problème d'achat 27 et à un chien qui a
un poil brillant qui ne présente pas de
ce qua non de pellicule au niveau de la
peau qui est vif joueurs qui bien sûr
n'a pas de problèmes au niveau des
aplombs on a à peu près les principaux
signes extérieurs de
de sa bonne santé
ap
il faut habituer à un cheveu du puits
sont arrivés dans un famille à être
soigné c'est à dire que il doit dans sa
vie avoir peut-être un moment où il faut
mettre les titres messieurs découvrent
les oreilles nettoyer les oreilles le
brosser défier ses ongles vérifier c'est
dans l'entretien des dents du chien est
très important en effet il se dépose à
la base de la danse des tartres et ce
tard très souvent responsables dans un
premier temps de charge est vite ensuite
d'affection dentaires les oreilles
doivent être propres et entretenues
régulièrement surtout si le chien a
tendance à produire beaucoup de sébum de
substances froid concernant l'entretien
des yeux on peut tous les jours à l'aide
d'une solution nettoyer le point les
yeux de façon à empêcher le
développement ici de coloration au
niveau des poils surtout sur les chiens
après claire à pointe-claire et labrador
a besoin uniquement d'un gant en
caoutchouc et en période de nous on
pense le gard deux fois pas jour pour
éviter d'avoir à passer l'aspirateur
propre vous non ne me paraît que le
jaune
la preuve n'est pas pareil non plus on a
beaucoup plus de problèmes de peau les
ex mâché le jaune touché le mois c'est
pas le même
c'est le même chien mais c'est pas le
même chien à l'intérieur de l'espèce
canine
on observe des différences de taille
très importante du plus petit chien est
plus grand chien le point peut varier de
moins de 20 kg à plus de 80 kg on
distingue trois catégories
la première est celle des petits chiens
de compagnie dont le poids ne dépasse
pas 10 kg ils sont souvent issus de race
rustique
la seconde concerne les chiens moyen de
11 à 25 kg ce sont des chiens de
compagnie ou des chiens d'utilité qui
posent en général peu de problème
l'alimentation
la dernière catégorie est celle des
grands chiens de plus de 25 kg ce sont
des chiots qui ont une croissance
l'ongle délicate et qui à l'âge adulte
vive fréquemment à l'extérieur et ont
donc des besoins énergétiques importants
ces différences de poids sa compagne de
différences anatomiques et
physiologiques
compte tenu de son point le labrador
appartient évidemment à cette dernière
catégorie
un gros chien comme le labrador a des
besoins différents de ceux d'un petit
chien et d'un chien moyen un grand chien
réclame une alimentation spécifique
grandes races qui varie suivant les
différentes étapes de sa vie
l'alimentation doit en tenir compte dans
l'intérêt de la santé du chien un chien
dans la halle en gestation à des besoins
qui vont augmenter à partir de la
cinquième semaine est un aliment de type
croissance pour chiots conviendra tout à
fait à cette étape de la vie de la
chaîne par contre durant la période de
lactation qui dure aussi elle même à peu
près entre six et huit semaines
il faudra donner une alimentation
différente
richement pourvu en protéines richement
pourvue en grèce minéraux et vitamines à
6 cette semaine les chiots doivent être
une alimentation différente du lait de
la mère donc une alimentation qui sera
plus riche en protéines plus riches en
énergie aux sites est à portée
essentiellement par les matières grasses
et plus riches bien sûr en minéraux pour
mettre en place ans colette et en
vitamines la croissance d'un chien de
grande taille et longue halte et son
poids de naissance doit être en effet
multiplié par 60 à 100 il sa croissance
dur donc de 18 à 24 mois
sous son apparence robuste le cheveu de
grande race est délicat plus ils gagnent
du poids rapidement plus il est exposé à
souffrir de troubles du développement du
squelette pour prévenir l'apparition de
déformation des os et des articulations
il est important d'utiliser un aliment
complet pour ceux de grande race avec
une faible teneur en matières grasses et
une teneur optimale en calcium et en
phosphore tout excès est nuisible à sa
croissance
lorsqu'on utilise un aliment complet les
apports supplémentaires en minéraux et
en vitamines et sont à proscrire
ils risquent de perturber gravement la
croissance osseuse
il est conseillé de donner trois repas
par jour jusqu'à l'âge de six mois le
volume de l'estomac du chiot étant
faibles il faut lui apporter cet aliment
petites quantités
une fois atteint l'âge de 6 mois on
pourra donner deux repas par jour moitié
matin à moitié le soir et ensuite si
vous pouvez durant la vie adulte du
chien continuer sur deux repas par jour
il n'y a aucune contre-indication à
donner de repas à l'âge adulte ces
besoins énergétiques varie avec les
conditions d'environnement
un chien de grande race vie en général à
l'extérieur et ils dépensent donc
beaucoup d'énergie pour maintenir sa
température corporelle
pour compenser ces dépenses il faut lui
donner un aliment très concentré en
énergie mais le problème est de ne pas
dépasser sa capacité digestives en effet
par rapport un petit chien un grand
chien à un tube digestif
proportionnellement plus réduit
d'estomac du chien est très dit la table
de un demi litre on refoule il peut
atteindre un volume de 7 litres comme
l'estonien est relativement mobile dans
l'abdomen
cela prédispose le chien à un accident
souvent mortelle la dilatation torsion
l'estomac en prévention il est
recommandé de diviser la ration
journalière en deux voire trois repères
cela lui évite d'avaler un volume trop
important et trop vite
corps à surveiller à l'alimentation du
labrador durant sa vie d'adulte et
veillez à ce que il ne sent pas de pas
trop un moyen assez facile c'est de
palper les côtes normalement ne doit pas
voir les côtes du chien mon doigt les
centimes alors il ya toujours une astuce
pour des chiens type labrador qui ont
tendance à prendre du poids on peut à ce
moment-là augmenter le taux de fiv dans
l'aliment et le chien aura l'impression
d'avoir mangé plus tout en recevant
moins de calories puisque les fibres
n'apporte pas du tout vers les grands
chiens dépasse rarement l'âge de 12 ans
pour tenter de freiner ce vieillissement
prématuré d'aliments du chien adulte
doit contenir de la vitamine c et de la
vitamine e et lutter contre les
dégénérescences cellulaire il doit
contenir aussi un niveau réduit de
phosphore pour protéger les reins vers
l'âge de 6 ans le vieillissement
s'accélère le comportement est moins
dynamique
le transit digestif se ralentit
l'appétit baisse
les aliments sont del moins en moins
bien assimilé à partir de cet âge
il devient important de proposer un
aliment très appétant contenant des
ingrédients spécialement choisis pour
être très bien toléré par des chiens
dans les capacités digestif diminuer cet
aliment devra posséder un nouveau de
phosphore encore plus réduit qu'à l'âge
adulte est bien sûr toujours contenir
des vitamines sels ou ces quelques
mesures lui permettront d'aider votre
chien à rester en bonne santé le plus
longtemps possible
voilà donc un chien dont le courage et
l'enthousiasmé sont à toute épreuve un
retriever idéal à la dent douce qui
aiment le travail sérieux et bien fait
les non-chasseurs l'apprécient tout
autant comme l'ami le plus fidèle
le plus affectueux mais la mode du
labrador d'appartements risque de porter
de graves préjudices à la race il faut
garder à l'esprit que le labrador n'est
pour le travail n'est pas heureux s'il
ne se sent pas utile il a besoin de
faire plaisir à son maître en lui
obéissant et de sentir que celui ci lui
fait confiance et surtout qu'il s'occupe
de lui